welcome to this video playing a legend a
legend with white I'm trying this new
some what's yeah quicker quicker
approach let's let's try that just a
little bit less talk check and a little
bit more speed because I'm really I mean
okay with sick of losing so much all
time I mean it could easily be resolved
by as you see getting a decent time
control on but this is probably never
going to be happy go going to happen so
let's see what we can do with the things
that are actually possible okay so it
takes that's an interesting choice and
the last Bishop g5 okay so this this
should be nice really this this pin F
form is a very very serious threat now
intending then e five and g5 is a move
that don't really want to play d5 and
FYI sd5 tonight somewhere night
somewhere I don't know where or f 4
immediately f4 that's also very very
serious I can do that why not Knight
takes Knight x e takes a five wins the
piece i believe due to the pin and if he
takes with the pond I can do night g3
and tending night age 5 or night f5 can
also be good but night h5 is the the
main thing also maybe just a five de fe
knight takes Bishop takes and sorry and
his pawn structure is totally destroyed
maybe I could have played a 5
immediately but this is going to be
dangerous in any case and I've even had
on the clock here so let's think about
it for a moment but taking must be right
mmm and now get this near the king queen
and 96 m looks like a defense 5 may be
against that no it's not doing this so
he lets me take him he allows me to take
ha I wonder maybe Queen d2 a size right
or f5 Queen d2 but then no no this is
not a good idea this is not very good I
won't be maybe on the edge file like
Queen G 4-h form taking on f6 looks nice
but he's got 98 and what what kind of
moves in IG ATM let's take this other
stuff is definitely not I mean night g6e
5 is just directly winning with Queen h5
coming that's never going to be black is
not no no this is over d 5 mm and Queen
h5 now this that's not defensible I
don't think so I thought like g8 trying
to get rid of the night quickly still of
course white should have a good attack
but I think it's this is even worse I
believe with the Queen comin to h5 very
quickly that takes takes maybe there is
some defense but some may be the rook
like d takes f takes rook c6 trying to
take the night or whatever but I hard
time to believe that and i'm one minute
ahead on the clock that's good
now more Queen arrived it's not a big
surprise I guess and this should be
right definitely but watch now exactly
Knight g4 know that sets nonsense I
cannot go e six that's not good
rookie one feels kind of lame
nice the White Knight g4 94 rook h8
looks like huh our rookie one yeah c'mon
let's play ep one first I'm not really
sure what to do here maybe maybe it's
still somehow holding for the moment and
I mean I simply don't I don't they don't
see a win here this ruckus is really an
annoyance maybe Queen g4 back Quincy
fall back tending night aged 5 and e 60
possible queen age for I have credential
I'm elucidating whoa yeah I think I'm I
think I should maybe have some dinner or
something get the recharge the batteries
I create for wow wow yeah Quinn h4 was a
possibility after Knight g4 this is why
I was having this idea in mind this is
just intending now the check and e6
maybe this is just sufficient the tech
is really strong check and e6 ya and
settle what I'm going to do now it
Bishop takes rook takes and there are
still other attacking ideas Bishop g6
and f5 and what what not it's it's
really a lot
queen h4 he has answered with e seven
months quite cute
I don't see a defense it's really as
such a huge attack so we just took them
yeah yeah let's just take it it's it's
okay also from a material point of view
so take g six and seven I guess 25 is
also good young yeah let's do this okay
and he's down on 13 success and now I
have five yeah with a with a fork black
resigns yeah this was one of those cases
where an inaccurate opening or a net
accurate play against the sameish took
its toll um here it is it is dangerous
but maybe I know if this is a sub and
that a computer might offend but for
human this is terrible you are the
computer is so giving me an edge already
but yeah after this f4 is is very very
very dangerous takes 93 m plus three
young yeah this is a disaster 97 and
that took on f6e five is also
interesting i think i missed em is
something area Quinn age five is
stronger yeah okay I wanted to play
quickly this time and Queen h5 would
have been easier yeah okay this is also
easily understandable i am threatening
here and this e5 is just opening up the
floodgates that's it just just far too
much hard too much attack something like
here and you know this is also in rook
f6 yeah
okay but this this also is still
dangerous King h8 takes ya 9898 is is
still just 1.3 according to the comp but
this some this should be should be
devastating one yeah all come moves and
Queen g4 is also the best so yeah I
think I'm I should be satisfied with
this i'm playing most of the decisive
stuff that the comp is giving at least
preserving a winning advantage like plus
3 here yeah okay so this is some this is
really an ok game I think what what he
did not do besides taking on d4 early it
was was a bit strange but he didn't play
this um this typical move like 98 which
which prevents the pin and when when
white gets in the pin I mean if white
gets in the pin it always will be
dangerous that's really a piece of I
mean some experience that I can can
definitely share yeah if I get in the
pin it will be will always be on a
tricky situation for black okay thanks
for watching